[Musique]
je vais m'enrouler dans du papier viens
me fissoler d'une corde épaisse me
coller trois timbr sur le front je vais
m'expédier à ton
adresse je prendrai ensuite de l'encre
rouge je mettrai dessus colis express je
grimperai dans une boîte aux lettres je
vais m'expédier à ton
adresse quand j'arriverai dans ta grande
ville une voiture m'amènera en vitesse
ton facteur me prendra dans ses bras et
me déposera à ton
adresse quand tu me verras devant ta
porte coupe la ficelle et puis sors-moi
décolle les timbres de mon front et
arrose-moi de
Coca-Cola quand tu m'entendras te dire
je t'aime plonge-moi bien vite dans un
bon bain froid enlève la colle d'entre
mes doigts et couche-moi dans un lit
tout près de toi
oui je vais m'en rouler dans du papier
bien me fissoler d'une Gorde épaisse me
coller trois Cindre sur le
front et puis je vais m'expédier à ton
adresse